[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
closing arguments may soon be presented
in the olympian attempted murder trial
he had a problem with a particular
border
we wanted to leave the farm
and
the person would not leave did michael
identify to you that order yes and who
was it the lauren cannabis plus a firm
trial date is now set in the deadly
waukesha christmas parade attack and the
pike county massacre why an expert
witness in the o.j simpson trial
testified at a pre-trial hearing but
first could a verdict soon be delivered
in the sarah lawrence college sex cult
trial it all stems from
one person according to the government
who they describe as the crime boss law
on crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
your host brian buckmart closing
arguments wrapped up tuesday afternoon
in the federal trial of accused sarah
lauren's sex cult leader lawrence ray in
new york city now the jury will
deliberate on the 17 counts against him
rey is charged with several alleged
crimes including sex trafficking
extortion money laundering and tax
evasion among others authorities allege
he exploited several of his daughter
italian's college friends to gain money
and power for a decade his alleged
crimes came into the spotlight after a
new york magazine article was published
in 2020. the government's key witness
claudio jury painted a grim picture of
what she says life was like for her
after meeting ray in 2011. she testified
to raise alleged physical and mental
abuse to gain control over her jury told
the jury she turned to sex work to pay
rey back after he convinced her she had
poisoned him and caused damage to his
new york apartment and his father's home
in north carolina the 31 year old
testified that ray had taken upwards of
two and a half million dollars she had
earned through sex work rey's other
alleged victims testified including
three siblings who shared more about
rey's alleged violence and threats ray's
defense attorneys have painted him as
the victim claiming the alleged victims
tried to kill him and destroyed his
property we've shared some of the
evidence the government has presented
which shows just a small glimpse of what
went on over the last decade within the
ray family
law on crime's adam classfield is
following this trial closely he was
inside the courtroom as closing
arguments were presented
the
jury has heard the entire sordid tale
the defense is trying to posit that this
is a group of storytellers they're
saying that
essentially encouraging jurors in their
words to go through the looking glass
and it was a constant refrain of the
defense summations that they believed
these stories that they believed larry
ray
when larry ray told them that he was
being persecuted by powerful enemies
that they were poisoning him that they
were all participants in this elaborate
tale that's how the defense wants to
view this but what the government is
saying and what hundreds and thousands
of trial exhibits videos audio tapes
shows that these were students who
suffered according to the government
extreme physical sexual
and mental abuse by a man who extorted
them for hundreds of thousands and
millions of dollars in some cases so
that's a story that the jury is going to
have to suss out into
more than a dozen serious federal
charges that can put larry ray away in
prison for the rest of his life
story indeed joining us today is legal
analyst matthew mangino and co-host
terry austin matthew what do you think
are the strongest points the prosecution
made in this trial that came through in
closings
well i i think they were very effective
in in painting this as a criminal
enterprise and and that leonard ray was
the patriarch of the rey family
and they laid out you know his ongoing
uh years and years of mental abuse and
physical abuse and sexual abuse and how
he controlled and manipulated uh these
college students uh friends of his
daughter um
to go out there and generate literally
millions uh in in uh profits from a sex
work and then to try to launder that
money and evade paying taxes on it i
think the prosecution was very effective
and methodically going through that and
explaining it to the jury yeah
definitely a very strong government case
here but let's look at the other side
terry is there even a single charge you
think the defense raised reasonable
doubt or do you think it's guilty across
the board i think we're going to see
guilty across the board on all charges
it was just too significant a case
against this man listen during closing
arguments today we heard mary bracewell
she's the assistant u.s attorney she
told the jury please convict him of all
charges and you know those charges are
racketeering conspiracy force labor sex
trafficking obstruction of justice if
anything maybe the defense could get the
obstruction of justice i didn't see too
much evidence as far as that was
concerned but i don't think the jury's
going to say listen you're guilty in
every one of these charges yeah maybe he
beats a charge or two at the end of the
day
any number of these charges can see a
severe amount of jail time for laurence
ray
thank you both an update now on a story
we first brought you here on law and
crime daily a second arrest has been
made in connection to the deadly
sacramental mass shooting on tuesday
police say 27 year old smiley martin was
taken into custody this comes just one
day after 26 year old deandre martin was
arrested in connection to the deadly
shooting officials say six people were
killed and 12 more injured last sunday
investigators say a fight broke out near
several popular bars and clubs in
california's capitol after that more
than a hundred shots were fired both
suspects now face multiple charges
including assault possession of an
illegal firearm and possession of a
machine gun in a statement the
sacramento district attorney says she
expects more suspects to be taken into
custody in relation to the shooting
spree
still ahead on law and crime daily a
trial date is set for the wisconsin man
facing nearly a hundred charges in
connection to the waukesha christmas
parade attack but first we look to ohio
for the latest developments in the pike
county massacre case our own angelette
levy is live with the newest details
from tuesday's hearing
[Music]
welcome back shoe prints and blood were
the main topic of discussion at the
hearing in the pike county massacre as
new details about the night in 2016 are
afoot law encrimes andrew levy is here
with the details
brian george wagner's lawyers argued
against an expert in shoe impression
analysis testifying for the prosecution
because the defense says the science
simply isn't reliable william boziak
offered an opinion to the prosecution
that shoe prints found in blood at the
crime scenes came from athletic works
gym shoes sold at walmart stores boziac
started with the fbi in 1970 and has
written books about shoe and tire
impressions
george wagner his brother jake and
parents angela and billy are charged
with murdering eight members of the
rodent and gilly families in april of
2016 many of those victims were asleep
when they were shot angela and jake have
pleaded guilty to the murders and
decreed to testify against george and
billy and according to court documents
prosecutors say angela admitted to
buying those athletic works gym shoes
for her sons to commit the murders
boziac says the texture of a shoe would
only be identical to one specific shoe
mold meaning he can display this
evidence and show it to the jury
what's what's great about this evidence
is that it's what we call demonstrable
so
i can take an enlargement or put it on a
screen
that's highly detailed
of the crime scene impression
and of the known shoe
and of test impressions i made from that
shoe
and i can
demonstrate
the basis of my findings that help me
reach my conclusion
and i can demonstrate that to
a court a jury an attorney
and technically they weigh the evidence
but the evidence is
demonstrable
and when you have demonstrable evidence
that's a big big test
of its reliability
in the end the judge ruled against
george wagner's defense team's request
to bar this testimony so that shoe
impression evidence and analysis will
come in the jury will get to see it and
there was another interesting fact that
we re we learned recently this came from
a motion that george wagner's team filed
asking to bar the testimony of jake and
angela wagner at his trial they said
that jake wagner told prosecutors that
george only went along that night at the
very last minute and didn't fire any
shots didn't kill anybody but he went
along to protect jade in case their
father billy tried to actually murder
jake after the murders were committed so
that was an interesting bit of
information we learned we hadn't heard
it before brian
interesting indeed and maybe a potential
defense down the road well back to help
us figure out junk science or not is
legal analysts matthew mangino and terry
austin terry what's the do dog sorry
standard used for deciding these
hearings and do you agree that the
footprint should come in at trial
well the dalbridge standard really came
from a supreme court case with that name
and it's just simply a hearing to
determine whether or not this expert's
methodology is valid and they look at
several factors what they want to find
out is has this been tested is it a
tested theory has it been subject to
peer review what is the error rate what
are the standards of control and most
importantly they want to make sure that
there is widespread acceptance in the
community for whatever that methodology
is so clearly this is what was
established today and so the judge
thought yes this is a standard that is
used and it was accepted all right so
it's coming in but the question matthew
i have is why bother with this doesn't
the prosecution have more than enough
forensic and witnesses you even have the
person who bought the shoe for one of
the defendants uh testifying so why the
the super imprint needed in the case
like this
well brian when i was a prosecutor when
it came to evidence uh you know too much
was never enough i was gonna go and get
as much evidence as i could that was
relevant and put it before a jury you
know trying a case is is somewhat like
uh playing in a football game without a
scoreboard you don't know whether to
take a knee uh you know or or to throw a
hail mary uh so so you you have to be
ready and you have to have as much
information that's relevant at your
disposal to present the most effective
case that you can absolutely i know
anjanette this isn't the first time that
william boziak has been involved in a
high profile case is it
no not at all brian he's a familiar face
in
criminal trials and most famously most
notably i should say he testified in the
o.j simpson trial back in 1995.
for those of us who remember that that
was some time ago but that was a trial
watched by people around the world and
he offered an opinion about those bruno
molly's shoes
that o.j simpson said he never wore but
he uh testified about the shoe
impressions left in blood in that case
and today he said he actually has
testified 500 times and not always for
the state sometimes is testified for the
defense and his testimony in some cases
has actually led to an accused being
exonerated so that was some interesting
information that came from the hearing
yeah not too long ago angenette i know i
was probably like seven or eight at the
time but i think i think we all remember
but thank you everyone for the update
coming up on law and crime daily we head
to new jersey where the trial of former
olympian michael barason may soon move
to closing arguments plus the deadly
waukesha christmas parade attack a trial
date is now set for defendant daryl
brooks
[Music]
welcome back in october childhood is now
locked in for the suspect charge in
connection to the deadly waukesha parade
massacre on monday 40 year old daryl
brooks appeared in court where defense
attorneys motioned for a delay in that
october trial date arguing they needed
more in time to prepare for the sizable
case in all brooks faces 83 charges in
connection to the deadly parade crash
that happened in november of last year
prosecutors say brooks drove his suv
past the barricades of the annual
waukesha christmas parade killing six
people and injuring dozens of others
brooks is charged with multiple counts
including homicide recklessly
endangering safety and use of a
dangerous weapon in the end judge
jennifer derow denied the motion to
delay the jury trial after hearing
heartfelt messages from family members
of victims and survivors of the parade
attack jury selection in the waukesha
parade trial is now expected to begin on
october 3rd
legal analyst matthew mangino and
co-host terry austin are back to break
down the latest in the coming deadly
waukesha parade trial
terry the judge denied the defense's
motion to start in 2023 but with all the
witnesses and victims do you actually
think the case can start this year and
what discovery would be needed in a case
like this
well i think a start date this year is a
bit ambitious but i do think it's
reasonable it started back in november
21st of 21 so this has been almost a
year october certainly would be a year
and i think listening to
the victims
family and all of the evidence that they
have really made the judge feel as
though they needed to start this case
and get the evidence in and and figure
out what was going to happen at the end
of the day look we know six people are
dead dozens were injured they're going
to be looking at the video there's lots
of video here out in the street people
were taking video they posted it on
social media we also know that there is
video just in the street so they're
going to look at that they're going to
talk to all of the multiple witnesses it
is going to take time so we'll see what
happens it's ambitious but i think it
can be done yeah just to give our
viewers some context like a one
victim homicide in brooklyn may take
about a year and a half two years to get
tried so this is quick matthew change of
venue will likely be argued all the way
up to the day of the trial how could
venue change uh trained jury selection
here
well you know it's you're correct i mean
the change of venue issue can go right
up to when you're already looking at and
and talking with the jury pool because
the question in change of venue is not
whether you've heard about this case and
certainly everybody is in that area is
going to have heard about this case but
whether or not based on what you've
heard you can continue to be fair and
impartial uh so so that issue of change
of venue can be revisited over and over
again as you're trying to get a a jury
seated for this case yeah it's gonna be
difficult i don't know what part of
wisconsin we're gonna find ourselves in
this case but best believe it's gonna go
to trial at some point in time and
closing arguments are moved to wednesday
in the trial of ex-icu dr william
hussell who cell is accused of murdering
14 patients while practicing medicine as
an icu doctor at mount carmel saint
anne's hospital in columbus ohio
prosecutors say whoso gave deadly
amounts of fentanyl to multiple patients
resulting in their murders defense
attorneys countered saying huso was
providing end-of-life care both sides
are expected to present closing
arguments on wednesday make sure to
watch the law on crime network for live
capital gavel coverage and up to the
minute developments in the case
when we come back the defense begins its
case in the olympian attempted murder
trial could closing arguments soon be
presented that's ahead on long crime
daily
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily we
head now to new jersey where we could
soon expect closing arguments as the
defense moves quickly through its list
of witnesses in the trial of michael
barrisson a man well known to the sport
of dressage accused of attempted murder
bearson is charged with two counts of
attempted murder after shooting lauren
canorack in the chest twice and shooting
at her then boyfriend robert goodwin in
2019. the dispute followed a string of
and back-and-forth arguments about
kanorak and goodwin's living arrangement
on barisone's farm at the time of the
shooting the two were living in an
apartment on barrison's property while
he trained canorac in dressage horseback
riding in a string of several 911 calls
days leading up to the shooting
barristone said he tried to evict
cataract and goodwin can iraq in turn
told dispatchers she was being harassed
barriston's defense team argued he
feared for his life at the time of the
shooting and suffered from mental health
issues on tuesday the defense called 10
witnesses before noon several of them
were barristone's former dressage
trainees barriston's former attorney
testified telling jurors about the
change he saw in his client leading up
to the shooting
did you notice changes in his affect as
it got closer to the date of the
incident absolutely
what were your observations he became
very very upset um
almost to the point of
being unable to function
as an attorney and this was my client
it got so bad i couldn't even have a
conversation with him he was um
in constant fear
of so many things and all he would talk
about he was in a loop
all he would do was talk about the fears
that he had
and and here i am trying to be a lawyer
to a situation and proposing
solutions or possible paths to take and
he wouldn't deal with him i don't think
i realized at the time you know how out
of it he was uh
and it only perhaps was later as we got
really close to the sixth and seventh
when he became just you know
non-functioning did the fears
relate to lauren cataract totally too
long can i
matthew the defense attorney's testimony
was interesting to me hear me out
because if a client has gotten to a
point where you can't represent them
like like we've seen in the vallo day
belt cases uh then typically you
withdraw from representing but that
didn't happen so what does that say
about barristone's mental health
well i mean you could interpret in that
way that that uh you know his lawyer
didn't go to the extent of withdrawing
you know from the civil case now this
was his private attorney who was helping
him with evictions not not his criminal
defense attorney um and you know there's
no issue here with regard to
confidentiality because obviously uh
michael barisson waived his
confidentiality to permit his lawyer to
testify about these things obviously
it's consistent with everything else
we've heard from witnesses on behalf of
the defense that he was distraught that
he was
catatonic that he wasn't able to
function and so i think it's important
testimony as they build their defense
here absolutely now terry defense
council has asked multiple witnesses
about barristone's mental state right
before the crime do you think that will
be enough to establish mental health
illness as a defense
i think it might be brian just because
the defense counsel asked almost every
witness that got on the stand whether it
was the lawyer that we just saw whether
it was someone who was fixing the shoes
of the horses he asked everyone did you
notice a change in michael barristones
his demeanor and most of them said yes
he was extremely distraught he didn't
understand what was going on and so what
he's going to have to show is by a
preponderance of the evidence in new
jersey this is an affirmative defense
he's got to show that there was mental
illness and so what he needs to do is to
make sure he's asking these questions
the way the charge is going to go to the
jury and i think so far he's done a very
good job of doing exactly that yeah it's
gonna be interesting and difficult case
we'll see how it continues but thank you
for joining us here on lawn crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
so
[Music]
you